so this grand project was funded by usda
nrcs
under the umbrella of cig the
conservation innovation grant
so this is a systems project where we
are going to evaluate
uh the adoption of cover crop the
economics of cover crop as well as
uh irrigation systems um and we are
gonna look into or investigate
the effects of cover crop and irrigation
and how these two practices
help reduce the nutrient losses uh into
the environment mostly nitrogen and
phosphorus
this grant is a unique grant and is
going to help us
understand not only the economics are
the economics part but we are going to
look into the social aspect
of adoption of conservation practices
one of the goals of the
grant is to work on co-development to
bring networks of farmers together
and i think when growers get together
and they can learn from the struggles
and the successes that other farmers
have had in their area
it really builds a community to learn
from each other
this grant project consists of six
objectives with the overall goal of
increasing co-development of knowledge
about the adoption of sustainable and
resilient production practices
these objectives include increasing the
knowledge and skills needed to implement
and manage cover crop systems
irrigation scheduling and variable rate
irrigation
increasing the knowledge of the impact
of cover crop and irrigation water
management
as it relates to efficient nutrient use
evaluating documenting and disseminating
the agronomic economic
and environmental impacts of
implementing and managing combined
practices of cover crops
and irrigation management
establishing a network of learning sites
in which farmers and researchers
work together to increase adoption and
improve management
of sustainable and resilient production
practices
and determining the barriers and
limitations
to implementing and managing cover crop
systems and irrigation management
through frequent farmer engagement it's
all about working to
promote practices that we know have a
positive impact on
soil and water quality so practices like
cover crops
precision irrigation nutrient management
so incorporating some of these practices
into one large
group of demonstrations throughout the
state of alabama
i hope that together with the research
team we will be able to see the power of
collaboration
with the growers that we're working with
and to be able to learn
from them about their most important
problems but then we'll also
learn new techniques for engagement with
producers
i think for the producer a lot of times
they are very removed from research
unless they're
part of the research and so i'd like the
idea that we're going to have multiple
agencies
that are going to work together as well
as the own farm trials
and so everybody's going to share in
this project they're going to share the
data we're going to learn and we're
going to make some mistakes
but hopefully we'll move the needle as
far as what
is capable production-wise on the farm
[Music]
the farmers would like to see positive
impacts on their farms in terms of
volatility
and perhaps return on investment but
farmers would like
also to see a positive impact to the
environment
as a result of the adoption of these
practices
so if we are able to show
to the farmers and the farmers will
see that these practices are going to
have
an impact to the environment there will
be
more ecosystem
services there will be more
environmental benefits
and economic benefits that
will be reflected on the communities
around those demonstration sites it's
good for everyone it's good for the
environment it's good for the farmer
because he's going to save money
it's good uh is is good for uh
from a social aspect because there are
several taboos that are associated with
the nutrient runoff and losses so we are
going to
tackle several problems at once
you